[Music]
the digital spit and the jowl shaking
that moment really you know kind of
broke realism for me in terms of like oh
this is a cg creation
my name is caitlin young i'm a visual
effects supervisor
i have been working in the visual
effects field for the last decade
and i'm also the founder of alpha
studios some of the shows i had the
pleasure to work on
house md the walking dead i'm currently
working on the latest season of grey's
anatomy
today we're going to be talking about
movie monsters and the visual effects
behind them
this character became the landmark you
know in which we measure
so many other you know creatures that
we're trying to bring back to life
and i think what made it really special
is having
animatronics on set and using computer
generated graphics later on to enhance
it's so
key to having actors to react to
something
and not have it just be you know a green
ball attached to a rope or you know
attached to a pole or something like
that
so one of the greats phil tippett you
can definitely see
all the attention to details him and his
team put in
in terms of the texture how the skin
glistens
in rain the beauty of having an
animatronic
on set is you don't have to really
necessarily guess the skill right that's
a giving for you
you're getting the scale of the t-rex's
head and the teeth
in relation to the kids and to the cards
you know even to
the flashlight with the eyes you're
really getting the weight of it
[Applause]
i had to guess there's probably wires to
make the
car flip over this is a great example of
a seamless blend
of practical and cg where you're not
really sure you know where
things start and where things ended but
i think it's a great handoff the pacing
and the editing and the framing
each composition is just so masterfully
[Music]
done
so this scene with the troll it did try
to do a blend of practical and visual
um like some of the other films that we
saw right so the cutaway is the three
characters
whenever you're seeing um part of the
troll right
whether it's leg or it's you know it's
wooden bat
those were practical but then whenever
you see the troll
and it's full frame that is you know
computer generated creature
there's lots of kind of boundaries right
that the digital artists have to take
into consideration you have the height
of the bathroom stalls and the height of
where the sinks are
and then you have these kids that you
have to take into relation
with how tall and wide this troll is
and you have the you know really complex
issue
of adding harry on top of a cg creature
so right this scene is very challenging
especially in the early 2000s
i think what was missing that might have
you know sold the shot
a little better is the amount of detail
in the skin right we just saw in
jurassic park
you know the scales as a sheen that
we're really missing from
this character right now
[Music]
it's too monochrome in terms of the
bumps
and where the skin begins and where the
jacket starts
[Music]
i also think you know we are so used to
seeing you know
humans and one of the tricky parts about
this scene is when harry jumps on the
troll
and you can tell that it's not you know
harry
as played by daniel radcliffe but it is
a computer generated harry
and having two complex you know
characters
on screen relying on post-production you
know i think
they did a great job for the time that
it is but there's definitely an
evolution of the creatures within this
franchise
oh troll bogeys
again we're you know at night time which
gives it just
enough of a wiggle room to hide any
imperfections
but i think the lighting on this is
superb of just kind of how it highlights
the silhouette just as you're seeing the
tips of the fur of the bear right you
just get enough details in the right
places
to really feel the weight of this bear
the size of
it i think they did you know great work
in terms of character design
really putting themselves into the realm
of this movie
where everything is a little bit mutated
within nature i love the sliminess the
patterns on the skin
like we're not sure what's eating away
at the skin the animation on the bear
was done particularly well paying
attention to the main
and secondary animation right with the
lymph that the bear has
where the eyes is looking where is this
gaze when the bear
opens its mouth right the tongue just
kind of has that one second hesitation
whether it wants to attack or wants to
explore
i think you can feel the breath coming
onto the characters
the cherry on top of gray visual effects
is sound design
when the bear says help me in this human
life way
you're almost getting the sense that you
know is there still a human
in there you know that it may have
absorbed you know from the past that is
trying to come out
with the design of despair is what's you
know kind of really selling
how crazy these mutations are happening
in nature which ties
really well within the story
[Applause]
[Music]
whenever i see large armies like this i
automatically think of the large army of
digital artists right
especially since the main character used
to be an actor in prosthetics
and in post-production they decided to
make him you know make this into a full
cg character
even though the scene is set at night
i'm not sure
where the light source is coming from
i'm seeing an inconsistency in the
lighting coming from the sky
and how each characters are lit i also
feel a shift in pixel definition
i feel um azog and his works they
almost feel too soft they're they're fur
and their textures whereas we get really
detailed facial expressions from other
characters i think the
the the juxtapose is what is adding to
the inconsistency of the scene
i think this is a tricky visual problem
to solve of
how to keep a human skeleton
skin a movement but adding just enough
reptilian
properties to it with the tail with the
skin i think
combining the specific actors facial
expressions
in this reptilian scale like creature
design
something about the eyes being so
human-like
i'm not sure i'm not sure if it's
selling how menacing this character is
within this interior lighting as well
we're really seeing the subsurface
scattering
of the reptilian skin
i think sometimes it's a little bit too
detailed and
i think it's making it stand out that
that this is a cg character
there's no need to stop me peter
[Music]
i really love the design of this
character
it's whimsical in the scariest way
possible
especially in in the facial feature
there's such detail to it there's so
many different clusters within the
eyeball itself
the number of shots that we see this
monster and
all the different environments are run
through i think this is
really impressive for the early 2000s i
think
it's particularly impressive that we get
to see the full body of the monster
so early on in the film especially in
daylight
as they interact with so many extras
without it being
hidden by anything i think they did a
great job of mimicking the surroundings
you know with the shadow
i love the reference of size and the
scale and the movement
in relation to all the other character
in the scene it plays together really
well
this hulk is really reminiscent of the
hulk uh imagery that we're used to
from the comics we're in early 2000s
this is the beginning of motion capture
um i think the facial elements right now
are not as detailed as they need to be
to sell this character as a main
character in the movie
i don't think we're getting that you
know human
likeness coming through right now the
color
it's this you know very very green
screen
green if you will i think the strong
green saturation
is overpowering the frame right where
you can't really pay attention to
anything else because there's nothing
else like it in terms of you know the
color palette
i do notice some inconsistencies in
terms of
scale like the the height of the box in
relation
to the hulk's you know physique are the
boxes
coming up to its knees right this is a
challenging character
with the size with a speed that needs to
travel
i think it's especially challenging to
keep
real physics and specific proportions
what's also really challenging
with the scene is we're going from an
interior to an exterior where
there's really nothing in frame that's
going to hide the cg character
and it's tricky to have photorealism
outside in plain daylight
i call it baby hulk right we're seeing
baby hulk as you know in the evolution
of hulk in the marvel universe in terms
of
color we definitely see the hulk gets
muted down
more and more and i think as the hulk
you know it evolves
we really see more facial features you
know from
the witness cam that the actors are
wearing you know giving it a reference
for the animators
to really mold you know this this larger
than life-size character
and give them more personalities in
addition to the sheer volume and size
they really get to see
how how this character thinks before he
acts as opposed to just
attacking everything on the scene
the textures within this character it's
metallic
enough for me to really believe that you
know this is an alien from another
planet
and the way that it moves with all the
tentacles and the randomness
how it spawns you know part of its body
as it's moving
the shape-shifting nature of these
creatures um i can't help it but think
what their rigging systems were like for
there to be enough controls to give it
specific design
and animation movement quality but to be
technical enough you know where
it doesn't take hours and hours and
hours for this character to go from one
spot to another
working so well with all the other cg
elements in the scene
right the smoke the sand simulation the
dust
i think all the other simulations the
sand the debris
they're all helping this character to be
grounded in the scene filming
in the daylight will make it difficult
you know for a cg character to fully
kind of pull its weight
but having all the additional
simulations i think it's what
is is what's kind of disguising it just
enough
for it to kind of visually sell that
this character has these particular
movements
and it's really their tentacles that's
kicking up all the dirt you're just
seeing enough of the character for you
to want to see them more
your doomsday
what they did well is the contrast
between
superman and how he has his steadiness
about him and then you're getting
something completely opposite in his
arch nemesis in a way you're seeing this
sliminess
where in the dead of night you're having
this dark moody color palette
i'm not sure though with the sliminess
of the skin and the way that it's
lit if it's really selling as this
menacing character
i think it's always challenging when you
have a monster
that has more of a human-like facial
expression
next to another human right maybe the
perfect human you know who plays
superman
the contrast of that you know is a
little bit hard for the eye
there's still something about it that's
not
reading photo realistic in the scene
that it needs to play in
um compared to other characters
the height the weight and the scale of
this particular character
i think it does change from shot to shot
also as they're fighting
over the sky you know going in and out
of these sets
there are times where it's just all cg
and i think our eyes
are picking up that you know these are
cg characters on screen right we kind of
left the world of realism for a little
bit and i think
it's because of the small
inconsistencies that we're really seeing
this character as a cg character
as opposed to a character that's in the
in the realm right
now you know fighting superman
[Music]
i believe they were animatronics made
for this character
to really study the interaction of
light it is especially fitting seeing
the two characters right next to a car
as a lot of r d went into studying
how car paints work in relation to
its environment essentially you know the
paint
and the texture of the metal becomes a
mirror
of whatever environment that they're in
all this was made possible by
image-based lighting
where you're taking a high resolution of
the surrounding to use as a reference
you know to light these cg characters or
at night time and
it's especially crucial for us to feel
that the characters are grounded in this
environment
and image based lighting is helping us
get the lighting and reflections
um accurately within their suits i do
like the subtle differences
in terms of the textures between our
hero and our villain
iron man does have this shiny quality to
a suit
whereas the villain has more of a dull
you know kind of worn down
metal look the design of the villain is
working especially well
taking in consideration his sheer size
and volume and mass
but he's still able to move with this
fluidity that's able for him to keep up
with iron man
having small light sources as eyes the
lighting source within the character
design
is working great for eye lines as well
star wars for many people and visual
effects right this
was our kind of starting point so the
one thing that's tricky for me right now
to believe that that this character is
really
standing in the scene with all the other
characters is the texture within his
skin
i think it's too monotonous right now
the amount of detail we have
in his skins and in his folds and also
how it interacts with his
clothing right his robe right his his
shoulder pads
it's so rich in costume design as it
stands next to other characters
with equally detailed clothing i think
the juxtaposition is making us realize
that this is a cg character
i'm seeing in particular with a wide
shot of everyone bowing
you can definitely tell a clear divide
of you know cg
and practical elements we're seeing this
character standing next to this tree
trunk for the majority of the scene
and the similarities in terms of
the textures the details in the tree
matching the detail of the skin with how
they're framed next to each other like
that it's not really selling for me
either way
of the character or the forest that
they're in with the design of this
character
my eyes are not going straight to its
eyes right i can't
look away from its mouth and its jaw and
you know all the bounciness
there's so much movement in the mouth of
this character
and it's giving us so much life but the
eyes
are not really giving it you know as
much emotion
[Music]
the digital spit and the jowl shaking i
think that moment
really kind of broke realism for me in
terms of like oh this is a cg creation
all the muscle movements feel a little
too unison the rubberiness
you know of the entire lower face
moving you know i think that gets
refined in later movies as we see other
characters
where you see more of a muscular
structure in a way
that makes sense you know to that
particular character
[Music]
like
[Music]
so we can't talk about good or bad cg
without bringing up the rock from the
mummy
in this particular scene i can't imagine
what the production was going through
whether it be a time budget or
production
restrictions because we know what the
rock looks like
seeing the rock's face in this low res
kind of
plasticky feel on this character how
smooth
his skin is and how all this hair kind
of moves in
and chunks within one another the lack
of facial details and mixed in
with you know in this rich environment
where everything else has so much detail
i think that's what's
making us painfully obvious that this is
not the rock
in my opinion the pinnacle of computer
generated work is when we can get
close-ups of cg human
and this was made in 2001 right this was
a very beginning
my buddies over the corridor digital
actually did a breakdown of this shot
where they're you know
attempting to fix it and make it and
make this character look more like the
rock
[Music]
as vfx artists we're constantly running
against time and budget
right sometimes we don't have time to
make other iterations
or really explore you know another way
of
solving this visual task i think it's
really easy for us to
you know sit back and judge all these
shots but i you know i do want to point
out that these jobs were made by people
right i think it's it's important to be
kind and thoughtful especially when we
don't know the circumstances they were
in
that they had to make these uh difficult
artistic decisions
[Applause]
this